foreign
[Music]
piece of advice I was given at the time
was don't talk to anyone this is from
her and her side of things this is
between you and me don't talk to anyone
about it and I took that advice you know
you don't get to throw grenades at my
house and then expect me to cover for
why their houses and Ashes
[Music]
hey what's up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show
thank you so much for joining us
on the show we talk about
what's going on in your life whether
it's your mental health your emotional
health parenting your relationships your
marriage who you're dating whatever's
going on in your world
we're here and we're gonna walk
alongside each other and figure it out
and we don't have to agree on everything
we don't have to vote the same way we
don't have to be excited by the same
things but we are committed to to
walking alongside each other and
figuring out the next right step
um hey big big day today we're supposed
to launch this with new music but
there's some drama Behind the Music but
check it out check out this awesome
cool uh new graphics here man if you are
uh listening to this on podcast make
sure you check out YouTube today they
did the the the art guys I don't know
what to call them the designers is that
is that their official names graphic
designers
or art guys whichever
graphic designers
not that I worked at a college with
graphic design as Majors but it's uh
they did a great job man it captures the
uh
yeah it's just right it looks good I'm
I'm I'm
excited I wish I had that kind of talent
I just usually look at stuff and I say
it needs to be more like Slayer and
there's always one guy in the room it's
like okay I'll take it from here
everyone else just thinks I can only
imagine and around and then they move on
anyway all right let's go to Sammy in
Billings Montana what's up Sammy
call Dr Don how we doing
good thank you for taking my call of
course thanks for being available what's
up yes uh well uh first uh I'm not the
native English speaker so I apologize in
advance I am a native English speaker
and nobody can understand me either so
we're in the same we're in the same boat
this morning
okay so um
I am a pathological liar
um and I don't believe you yeah just
kidding uh tell me tell me about it
well uh
I don't know when like it it exactly
developed but I mean I start I started
affecting my like job performance right
now and uh
I guess uh my family life too and um
yeah so uh
I don't know how to uh solve this
um what do you lie about
well even the like smallest
insignificant thing like I lie about
them and sometimes I embellish events
and uh
yeah and uh I know but give me give me
some examples what do you lie about
well
uh sometimes like uh I would be talking
to a friend and my wife would ask me
about what I was talking about and it's
like nothing significant but I tend to
lie about
that
so uh um
things like this and uh
uh I guess last week I lied about some
uh something I did like I made a mistake
on my job like a really small mistake
but
I didn't tell anyone and uh
uh
uh I guess uh they found out and
it made it worse than it is yeah it
usually it usually does how long um
how long have you been in the states
uh so 10 years 10 years so I'm yeah so
I'm originally from the Middle East okay
and uh how old are you
uh Thursday too
did you lie when you were 21
uh yes yeah so
I'm so uh
back home uh I had a
uh really like my dad was scary dude and
uh
I think he he
so maybe I think I started lying first
to him when he was like wouldn't ask me
about stuff when you say scary dude was
he abusive did he hurt you
uh
please
not a lot but more like more probably
but some something some physical
uh not a lot I mean but some
yeah like I guess four or five times
okay
um yeah sorry go ahead let me let me
jump in here so
anytime we have
um some type of behavior that in a way
becomes automated or becomes a habit it
becomes a a default setting
I always want to and back out and take a
thirty thousand foot view of of the
behavior and always want to ask one
overarching question
in for the last 150 years or so maybe a
little bit longer the questions we have
asked at that 30 000 foot view range
from what happened to you when you were
a kid to what's wrong with your brain
chemistry to any number of of questions
the question I don't hear asked very
often that I'm trying to be more
assertive in changing the Public's
narrative and how we answer how we
approach some of these challenges and
this is where whether I'm I'm reaching
for junk food when I get stressed or
whether I reach for another drink when I
get frustrated or when I respond to a
text of somebody I'm not married to
because it makes my heart be a little
bit faster or if I just default to
telling the TR to lying all the time
the question I want us to ask is what is
my body trying to protect me from
because I'm convinced that all of the
all of the architecture of where some of
these challenge of where these
challenges distill in the brain and in
the body
Cascade out in a million different ways
physiologically and genetically all
these things are all over the place
but at the core is you have a body
that's trying to protect you
from what getting her hit when you were
a kid or getting screamed at when you're
a kid
um
getting left by your wife being judged
getting fired from your job and being
ashamed
what is what is your body trying to
protect you from Sammy
and this and by the way this isn't just
in moments when you lie this is all the
time this little machine is running
underneath the surface
I guess being discovered
um what's what would what would somebody
find
I mean
logically speaking it's not anything bad
I mean relatively compared to yeah but
let's take logic out in the window
because logically
not admitting to a small little issue at
work doesn't make sense and so logic
doesn't count here
be honest what is your body trying to
protect you from
can I throw some things out there that
might help
yes I bet you are and tell me if I'm
wrong
I bet you are profoundly
and deeply lonely
I bet your wife is one of the only if
not the only people that you can truly
count on and even that has a strange
hierarchy in the relationship to it
and your friends are kind of your
friends but they kind of work together
my guess is you've got stress about
money my great guess is you've got
stress about a whole family unit back
home telling you what you need to be
doing and how successful you need to be
am I onto the right track at all
yes
um
I uh
yeah I don't know I think I
I have two personalities like one that's
is high then the other is what I face
the world okay I'm I'm convinced that
the the core human need is this
when you distill everything down the
core human need is this
if people actually knew me would they
still love me
and here's my promise to you
um
let me back out there is no psychiatric
consensus so if you look at all of the
the literature there's no consensus on
pathological lying as a disorderly even
took it out of the last DSM-5 for people
who give a crap about that stupid book
they they it it's it's not even a
tangible concept if you will
it's floating around right and so we're
going to ask ourselves what is our body
trying to protect us from and you've
given me in just a few short minutes
you've given me some insights you come
from a really abusive home you're
dropped into
Billings Montana as a kid who grew up in
the Middle East who's learning the
language in real time you're like trying
to change the oil on the car as you're
driving you have a job with a lot of
stress you've got a marriage you're
isolated you don't have your whole
Community with you all the time
and as you mentioned you've got an
inside guy inside your body that thinks
a certain way and talks a certain way
and has certain views on the world and
you have an external way you present
yourself Carl Rogers called that a lack
of congruence you have to bring the
outside the inside out
okay and so here's what that looks like
you have to find people that you can
trust
that you will say those inside things
out loud period
I'm terrified about fill in the blank
I hate fill in the blank
the politics of so and so makes me want
to vomit if I see another fill in the
blank fill in the blank fill in the
blank you have to be committed and if
you cheated on your wife you've got to
say it out loud
if you did some things in the Middle
East that you're not proud of and you're
here trying to recreate your life you've
got to speak them out loud you've got to
find people that you trust that might be
a therapist
that might be a religious Pastor a
religious leader that might be a couple
of close close friends but you have to
make that commitment and then when it
comes to lying I want you to change your
identity completely okay here's how we
do that
I want you to begin to repeat on a daily
basis
I am a man who only honors the truth
I'm a man who only speaks the truth I'm
a man who only says the truth and you're
gonna have to practice being awkward in
those moments
so let's practice
it'll get better it will get better only
if you go all all in this is like
stopping drinking
if you're an alcoholic you can't limit
your drinks to Fridays and Saturdays
because you'll end up
hungover until Thursday and then you'll
start right back up again
this means that you're going to say
something your wife's gonna come in and
say who you're on the phone with and
you're going to say oh it's my dad but
actually it wasn't it was a friend from
work
and you're going to have to stop
yourself and say I just told you my dad
that wasn't true
it was my friend from work
your wife's going to come in and say hey
where were you last night and you're
gonna say oh I had to work late and
you're gonna have to stop and go no I
wasn't
I was out with some friends
I stayed late talking to this woman that
I kind of have an attraction to and we
probably need to talk about whatever the
thing is you screw something up at work
you're gonna stop what you're doing and
go find your immediate leader and
supervisor and say hey I just made this
small mistake here's how I'm correcting
it or here's how I've already corrected
it here's how I'm about to correct it
you're going to practice telling the
truth and when you tell it you're going
to feel so exposed and naked and
terrified I want you to feel that
absolutely feel that in your bones
and exhale
this is the the heading into that storm
I'm a guy who only tells the truth I'm a
guy who tells the truth I'm a guy who
tells the truth
and I will tell you Sammy I was a guy
that lied about everything to everyone
all the time
always
and then I changed my identity and now
I've become pathological about
truth-telling to the point that I have
to be careful because I can come across
as a jerk about it
but
there will only be telling the truth
from this point forward
your relationships aren't worth it your
mental health isn't worth it your
emotional health isn't worth it losing
your wife isn't worth it losing your
job's not worth it tell the truth bring
the inside guy out
let the world meet that guy
be fully you
be full of you we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
this show is sponsored by better help
hey folks all of us need a little
guidance sometimes in life we're faced
with tough situations and choices and
the way forward isn't always clear I've
been in that position in fact I'm in
that position right now and therapy is
helping me find a path through it
whether it's a career decision
relationship at a Crossroads or some
other struggle you're facing you need
someone to talk with to move ahead with
confidence so if you've ever considered
therapy I recommend better help better
help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey to discover who you want to
become betterhelp is entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and it fits
your schedule whatever your schedule may
be just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge
so let therapy be your map with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go out to SLC
let's go out to Salt Lake City and talk
to Eric what's up Eric
hello hey man
hey John thanks for taking my call again
yeah man and so you called in in back in
2021 about a divorce you're thinking
about a divorce tell me about that
so golly that's a lot it's a recap
was my wife gave me a an unexpected uh
news it was on our 11th anniversary that
she had been working to get a divorce
and I didn't know it was coming
I hadn't we hadn't talked about it the
divorce or separation it was never at
least from my perspective on the table
and uh
I was pretty broken uh to say the least
and I called in looking for some for
some advice on how to first of all how
to cope and how to move forward and how
to work on some of my issues did I screw
it up and uh
no no it's anything I was a screw up man
you you were your advice was uh uh uh it
was potent in a good way it it was some
advice that I needed to hear that I
didn't have anyone else to tell me what
to do namely
the thing I wasn't doing is I wasn't
talking to people I was isolating and
trying to be private about it and you
said dude get some friends in your world
yeah and so I uh I took that advice the
best I could and furthermore
decided to make myself better rather
than blaming the situation and that's
what I'm working on for a couple years I
love it dude so how can I help you today
man
so without uh attempting not to get into
too much detail
I you know the one very bad piece of
advice I was given at the time was don't
talk to anyone this is from her and her
side of things this is between you and
me don't talk to anyone about it just
you know maybe your parents or something
but don't talk to anyone this is between
you and me and I took that advice oh no
did you I did well that was before that
was before I spoke with you and oh did I
have the same written did I have the
exact same responses I just did
you don't get to throw grenades at my
house and then expect me to cover for
why their houses and Ashes like if you
blow my house up you can blow it up I'm
gonna tell everybody all right you don't
get to tell me geez and I wish I I wish
I would I had done that you know what
you're saying at the time I was I was
desperate to save my marriage I was
already in the process before I got the
news that of working on myself and being
a better husband and and uh I was It was
kind of you know one of those three
steps forward four steps back two steps
forward one step back in one of those
that I was making progress and so I was
surprised to get the news anyway the so
I I tried to comply in order to in my
head I was the story I was telling
myself was
if I show her I'm being kind and
compliant then she'll see that maybe I
am more workable and than she thinks and
maybe she'll come around
and uh and that's Eric thinking that
this divorce ever had anything to do
with him in the first place
yes and that's been part of my journey
over the past couple years is realizing
this has a lot less to do with me than I
was led to believe Eric she bailed on
you because something was going on with
her
yeah you don't you don't drop a bomb on
an 11th anniversary with no
conversations no lead up no discussion
unless something's going wrong sideways
inside of you
I'm sure in retrospect you you've I'm
sure you could have done things
differently let's make no mistake but
absolutely brosh
yeah that's not on you it would be
unfair of me to say
it was all her you know I had I had my
own issues they weren't nearly to the
extreme that she has since led me to
believe but there there were some
problems uh many of which you know your
last caller was talking about honesty I
had some honesty issues sure that I had
to work on and I've gotten a lot better
at over the years and so awesome tell
him man it does it does get better but
you also heard my question right
um what's your body trying to protect
you from and sometimes people develop
dishonesty because they grow up in such
toxic sick situations that their body
knows if you tell the truth here it's
simply not worth getting hit over over
and over and over and so let's create a
neutral path it's like a like one of
those walkways in a in an airport like
it's just like a moving sidewalk I'm
just gonna create that so that I can
have a frictionless life right it's not
it's still dishonesty it's still alive
it's still not true
um but man sometimes people come by
their dishonesty honestly right
yeah but so where are you right now yeah
so so to Circle back to your question is
I have I I took much of your advice and
put my shoulder to the wheel and I've
been working on me for well since 2021
and I have come along with therapy
uh built you know rebuilding some
relationships with family and uh
essentially making myself be the guy
that I want to be and it was a hard it
was and it is a hard Road it continues
to be a hard Road right but I like the
Eric today
infinitely more than I liked the Eric
back then dude that's awesome man good
thing it's it's you know in your call
was instrumental so thank you now you
asked what is my question so despite all
of my growth despite all of the progress
I've made
during that divorce process because I
did keep to myself
what I didn't know is that she was not
of course
and she had been going to anyone in our
universe who would listen including my
dear friends and family members
with wild accusations that I never heard
in the courtroom you know such as he was
abusive he was
controlling he didn't let me spend money
he didn't let me visit my family the
things that were wildly untrue
and uh unfortunately I don't know what
to attribute to social climate or what
have you but a lot of people vast bulk
of people
at best decided to cut ties with me Eric
I'm gonna tell you something really hard
I'm gonna interrupt and tell you
something really hard yep thank God
they're gone
here's why
if one of my if my wife called any
number of my buddies this isn't just
limited to my core crew
any number of my friends is she called
any number of her friends
and said John is abusive
he won't let me fill in the blank
the number of them that their first
instinct would be like no way
followed by I'm calling him
or I'm going I'm showing up at his house
it would be a flood
because I've got that level of trust and
rapport with him they know me I'm an
open book I'm just I'm as wide open as
could be now if she called her friends
it's like John's always late to
everything and he's a goofball and his
music is terrible yeah they believe that
no question about that right but here's
the deal the fact that those people in
your orbit
never came to you with that never
challenged you on that never met you in
your front yard and said who Do You
Think You Are
and gave you an opportunity to explain
you don't want those people in your life
because they were never a part of your
life to begin with
they were leeches they were hanger ons
they were along for the ride or for the
party dude but they weren't in it with
you
and I know it's it's hard when you think
I had it's like having a hundred
thousand followers on Instagram and
suddenly they cancel all the Bots and
you're down to twenty thousand
and it hurts because you lost 80 000
followers but you they weren't real to
begin with
that's what just happened with you and
you can look at the landscape and the
number and see how it just it it went
zooped and dwindled down but man I'm
telling you right now you're in a better
place to rebuild something new forget
those folks and you you've listened to
show long enough I don't normally say
that I have little little patience at
all
for friends who don't have the courage
to say let me talk to him
I I invested enough that I'm involved in
this because we're we're we're close
we're connected we're friends we're
family I'm calling them if you don't if
I'm not worth a phone call then so be it
and you know it's I'm grateful you said
that I I'm coming around to to finally
believing that my folks gave me similar
advice and
I think
uh to wrap up the background and to get
to the actual question I suppose is
I think it made it really hard for me
not to believe the accusations because I
thought we were ride or die I was a guy
who
showed up when we're moving I was the
first guy to show up I was the guy who
showed up when you're hurting
I was I was the one who as you say I did
show up on the yard
I did call them
and so when everyone else seemed to bail
you know it devastated me so it's just
the actual question it was
despite my growth I have this I didn't
used to be this way but I have this
really uncomfortable uh
defense mechanism in my body I guess
let's make it difficult for me to
I thought I was doing everything right
as a friend
why is it that you know I guess what I'm
saying what am I trying how do I
articulate that I'll answer it because I
know you're trying to say you got to go
again
yeah it's kind of like talking to
somebody and they're like hey I've got
this much money to buy a house but I
live in California and houses are
tripled the the price as they are at
Canton Kansas so is it cool if I just go
ahead and buy this and I would tell them
like math doesn't get a pass in
California
and so I would tell you
your wife burned the landscape clean
and you got to see what trees in the
field remained and there was many fewer
trees than you thought
and that doesn't give you a pass on all
the loneliness research that exists that
says if you don't have a group of people
you can be yourself with be vulnerable
with you will die
and I'm feeling that you know it's been
nearly two years now and it's been I
still feel pretty lonely there are some
new people in my world that are
get into that friendship point but it's
definitely a loneliness haven't felt in
a long time so I guess the are there any
tools
that I can develop or get
to help myself open up again and be
myself with people uh to to open myself
up to be vulnerable
the only ones that I've seen be
effective at all and the science on this
is is dismal and again it's hard right
it'd be really hard to do a like a
controlled study on this
but
the two things I've seen be successful
is find shared experiences and go first
what I mean by that is join a soccer
team or a softball team or a
chess club join an existing thing where
y'all can do a thing together where
you're not just sitting at dinner
staring at each other and being like so
how do you feel because that's awkward
and weird but go to the fights go to the
fights go to the fights and eventually
like has happened
um I watched the UFC fights with a group
of guys and we every time there's a big
fights we all get together at one guy's
house and we watch them and after two
three four five times somebody texted me
and said hey when you go to lunch
and then things got real but we had
shared experiences we were cheering we
were laughing we were ragging and making
fun of each other having a good old time
and then there was some safety built so
that someone could say hey I needed a
question about my kid
or
um the second one is just go first and
be weird you be the house that every
time there's UFC have people over or
whatever sporting event or whatever
Bible study or whatever thing is like
hey I I just went and bought five
thousand dollars worth of Rogue uh
lifting equipment I've got to work out
at my house every morning at six o'clock
you guys are all welcome maybe one guy
shows up maybe no guys show up but maybe
if you guys will show up and then one or
two of them will continue to show up and
then y'all will go grab coffee together
we all go hunting together you go
fishing together you go I I don't know
go knit sweaters together I don't care
what you do but
um
it's easy to get into this
circling the airport in the plane where
you're waiting for somebody to invite
you and nobody invites you and that that
reinforces the message that everyone
sucks and that nobody wants to be around
you or you go and it's a little bit
awkward a little bit weird and that just
reinforces that every you see what I'm
saying it just kind of it's
self-perpetuating so the only way
through it is through it you have to
head into the Storm Into the Storm Into
the Storm over and over and over again
and your body is doing exactly what it's
designed to do which is to keep you from
getting hurt again
and I wish there was any other way
around it you just can't get a pass on
math right it just is it just I mean
just I mean this is this is the brutal
part of getting having somebody break
your heart
mm-hmm
it's like getting bit by a rattlesnake
and yet the only way to live is by
handling rattlesnakes right you got to
go back out there again and risk it
again
well I've done hard for a couple years I
can keep doing hard for a little while
longer I think
can I can be super honest with you I
think you've done
peripheral hard
which you have to do right you got to
keep the lights on and the bills paid
you got to keep food in your stomach
right I think you're about to enter into
the season of super hard the beauty of
super hard is I have found it's if you
will head directly into it it's not as
as long as people think it is
but it is painful
that might be taking six or seven of
those folks that actually just
completely bailed on you call them back
take him for coffee
and say hey what stories were told about
me
why didn't you call
like was that not worth a phone call
and there might be some closure there
and people may say hey I'm really sorry
because also two years ago was the
millikov and everybody was crazy
everybody was scared everybody was
everything
and so it may be worth you circling back
and letting people have the opportunity
to say I'm so sorry I screwed this up so
bad
and you can rebuild something there
maybe
sure that seems logical to me but I
would pick five or six of them that you
love and if you don't reach out to them
write them a letter that you're never
going to send
and just let him like get that out of
your body onto a piece of paper
I thought I was at least worth a phone
call I thought I was at least worth the
confrontation at my front door
if you thought I was really abusing my
wife I was really controlling her and
wouldn't let her call out the phone
would let her visit people
that's crazy behavior was that not worth
that a phone call
and quite awesome Eric they may say well
you did this and this and this and so it
was a logical and you may find out man
I've really had a lot of growing because
I kind of put this image out there who
knows what you'll learn
But ultimately
hardest part about broken relationships
is that our body puts a GPS pin in there
and says never again
those relationships got us hurt last
time we're not doing this this time
the only way to health and healing and
being well is with other people so you
got to go again and you got to go again
head on the line Eric I'm gonna send you
all of the questions for humans cards
for friends
um Jen like I don't know guys night
girls night friends couples and I'm
gonna send you a copy of own your past
change your future too
um
check it out it's got a whole section in
there about making friends
um give that a read and then dude call
me back anytime I'm really really proud
of the work you're doing it's amazing
we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hello.com deloney
all right we're back let's go to Zoe in
Atlanta Georgia what's up Zoe
hi
how's it going
it's going good I'm super nervous I'm a
huge fan oh gosh don't be nervous thank
you for being a fan but don't be nervous
I'm I'm I promise I'm not very good at
this what's up
okay so basically in essence like I
guess a simple question is how do I deal
with having anxiety or postpartum
anxiety specifically
um with my husband who doesn't really
understand mental health or really like
believe in mental health issues I don't
know if that's the correct way to word
it
um but I guess I can give you background
information if that's helpful
yeah because my first thought is well
you should just leave them but that's
probably not that's probably not going
to be helpful
um so
yeah
sorry one second
from another country so they don't
really talk about mental health the way
we do here in America that's and he also
has never had any mental health
struggles I guess but I've always kind
of dealt with anxiety so I have a little
bit more experience with that it's not
that he doesn't believe in it but he
kind of equates having anxiety to stress
so if I'm diverse telling him like oh
I'm anxious he's like what are you
anxious about like just go fix it and do
what you need to do to not be anxious
when it's not really that simple so he
doesn't understand I guess it's more of
a complex issue where I can't just go do
the dishes and then no longer be anxious
you know
have you gone to see a counselor
I haven't okay that's we need to start
um a couple of things one
you can't continue to go to
a source for
somebody to hear you to connect with you
when they're telling you I don't know
how to connect with you I don't I don't
even yeah this connection is never going
to happen
and so I do think it can happen but you
have to decide to stop going to him for
that because he can't provide that for
you he doesn't have a he doesn't have a
cultural context for it
my hope would be someone who didn't have
a cultural context could have a
scientific context or have a
um professional context and so I want
you to go to a counselor
and get some support and care there and
at some point invite him to come with
you
okay do not do that at the beginning
because you're gonna have to
be you're gonna have to do the work you
need to do to heal the ecosystem that
has given you this anxiety and some of
it if it's from before you were pregnant
there it could be any number of things
um if it's postpartum then it could be
any number of things but you need to sit
down and get that stuff worked out and
begin not worked out in a
um you need to fix that that's not I'm
talking about yeah but you need to get
some tools and get some insights into
why your body is trying to protect you
in that way trying to take care of you
in that way and what alarm Bells it's
sounding
and then invite him in and hopefully a
professional
who's got an ability to teach and inform
can give him insights that he's not able
to hear from you
okay that's that's helpful quit going
back to him for it because he's not
gonna he's not quit going back to import
he's not going to give it to you okay
and I just want to say he is like
incredibly supportive and loving and all
of that it's just he doesn't understand
so he doesn't know how to like support
me in that area and the way that I need
to be you know so I think it is also
probably for me to go seek well and let
me let me dig into that for a second
when you say he's not able to support me
what do you think you need when it comes
to support
um
I don't like sometimes times I guess I
just want him to be like you know I'm so
sorry that you're struggling today and
kind of give me a hug and things like
that like I was talking to him about it
last week and he was like because he
works from 10 a.m until midnight five
days a week so it's I'm basically a
single mom five days a week and so
um that can just add a lot of stress
into my life and um so I was talking to
him about that last week and he was like
well maybe you need to go get a hobby
like play tennis or something and I was
like I mean I'm lucky if I can shower
for more than three minutes at this time
so I'm not really looking to go
play tennis you know yeah but um it
sounds like a guy that
I'm not trying to give him a pass but
he's not going to be able to help meet
your needs and support you in the ways
that you need unless you're very
explicit in how you teach him
yeah because how would you recommend I
just like this my wife and I have had to
come up with a whole different language
because like him when she said she was
struggling with something I just solved
it because I'm a genius and I know
everything yeah right and come to find
out my wife is 10x smarter than me she
didn't need my
my
advice she needed me just to sit with
her and listen and say that sucks
yeah and so she taught me that
by saying this
hey I know you love me and I know you
want to connect with me
and when you told me just to go play
tennis that tells me you don't even have
a clue as to what I'm working through so
can I teach you in real time how to love
me better
if he says no to that then you'll have
bigger issues
like most men he would say oh God please
anything any sort of data would be
helpful yeah because here's what I bet
happens I bet you reach out and you say
man today was this and the kid diarrhea
all over me and puked on me and then we
had a lunch date and then they got
canceled
and
he responds with how he would deal with
those situations
yes yeah and then he feels you get
disappointed and mad at him
and he doesn't know why his wife doesn't
like him very much and you don't know
why you can't just sit with me and be
quiet it's all that
see what I'm saying yeah that's that's
that's perfect and it's yeah exactly
what it is where he tries to help and he
really does try to help but he doesn't
like like you said with your wife he's
more solution oriented so he's like well
what do we do and sometimes it's not
like there's nothing you can really do I
guess I just want support that way so
and don't use don't use words like
support
use words like
um my wife will say this and we've been
married for almost 21 years she will say
I just need you to sit by me and hold my
hand while I tell you this
and that's a signal to me to be quiet
and then sometimes she will say I am
being vulnerable and I'm gonna ask for
your thoughts on this
and I'm not gonna lie when she says
those words I want your thoughts I get
so fired up and excited that I can
actually
feel like I'm helping
because I'm so insecure in my own
presence that I think the only way I can
help is by running my mouth which isn't
true
yeah but she taught me
she taught me
yeah the same as in the morning her is
Her Sacred private time like that's like
it's just
such an important time
and so for years I would wake up and I
am bouncing off the walls at 5am and
she is like a like a ghost coming out of
a Mist like kind of slowly the the
molecules are finally coming together to
form a human and I'm like hey what's up
uh and so she had to teach me hey you're
a lot in the morning and I had to teach
her
it really breaks my heart that you won't
at least say good morning
and
she says good morning every morning now
and it's awesome we have a moment and
I'm quiet
I take my drama downstairs right you
know what I'm saying so all to say is we
honor each other by not asking each
other to read our minds
yes we don't say words like support or
um
or care for me or love me I gotta be
specific gotta be explicit here's what I
need and then
you got to be prepared for the
vulnerability because if you tell him
exactly what you need
and he goes nah I'm not doing that
then you have to deal with the fact that
you're married to a jerk
but most people just skip straight to
jerk and they don't ever give their
spouse or their boyfriend or girlfriend
or whoever they love the opportunity to
fully meet their needs because they
don't say them out loud
all right
my guess is is you will honor him
by
being very explicit about your needs
that he will meet those needs
and begin to connect deeper with you
and
your anxiety will slowly start to fade
yeah I really do think that that is the
case he's very responsive whenever I do
need anything from him
um I think you're right my problem was
like thinking of support as just this
General thing and not being specific
about what I need
so I think that would be really helpful
that's awesome and here's how it starts
the conversation if I'm you
I would start with
I've been using these big amorphous
words like support and care
and I've left you to to guess and try to
figure it out and that's not cool
and so I'd like to love you and honor
you by being specific
and so there's gonna be two ways you can
help me one I just need you to sit by me
and listen ugh
or sometimes I might ask you for your
insights and I'm gonna ask you please
don't don't
um give me advice or your wisdom if I
don't ask for it
but I promise I'll ask for it when I
need it
just give him that
give him that
also I want y'all to try SOS skin on
skin contact four times a day doesn't
have to be sexual in fact it usually
isn't it can be if you want to knock
your lights out but it doesn't have to
be
just right when y'all wake up in the
morning
just 10 15 30 seconds holding hands
putting your foot on his foot under the
covers right before you leave he leaves
for work right when he gets home
um
and then right before bed and he works
till midnight so maybe that's not
possible but do it the best you can
get some skin on skin contact no talking
no solving no no
running through the ticker tapes just
being together
let that exhale happen
thank you so much for the call Zoe and
please um if you continue to have
postpartum anxiety
this anxiety is new after you've had a
baby
um please go see your OB GYN it's your
doctor and
let him or her know hey that you're
still struggling with this because it
may be completely outside the realm of
just emotional health maybe some true
biological things going on thank you so
much for the call we'll be right back
all right as we wrap up today's show I'm
gonna go with the old classic one of my
favorites of all time
you gotta love the Great and Powerful
Don Henley
and
these little kids name The Ataris
covered this song and man I gotta say
uh not a huge remake guy they crushed it
songs called The Boys of Summer by the
great Don Henley
says nobody on the road nobody on the
beach I feel it in the air The Summer's
Out Of Reach empty Lake empty streets
the sun goes down alone I'm driving by
your house though I know you're not home
but I can see you your brown skin
shining in the sun you got your hair
combed back and your sunglasses on I can
tell you my love for you will still be
strong
after The Boys of Summer have gone
I'm not a boy of Summer I'm more of like
a
yeah just kind of a sad winter boy
love you guys see ya
[Music]